[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Hotel clearly Lewis it's an idyllic
surroundings some 90 kilometers north of
Stuttgart the health and fitness area
was redesigned in 2008 spacious and
luxurious it exudes peace and
tranquility no wonder the 4000 square
metre complex is a popular destination
for visitors seeking some relaxing time
out in recent years the hotel has
scooped up a number of awards originally
from Switzerland manager Thomas
Zimmerman believes the hotel strength is
in its customer service it's to me spas
are about finding the time to relax in
the width and troponin what sets us
apart are the staff they treat each
guest as an individual banking
[Music]
most of the visitors are German in fact
Germans are Europe's top health tourists
with an average of 3.3 million trips a
year
massages are popular as our natural
treatments such as local cold-pressed
red grape oil it's supposed to boost
cell protection and reduce the signs of
aging
[Music]
the Mohammed net how become what we
offer grapeseed facials
he said stick to some we make a paste
out of grapeseed flour and cold-pressed
grapeseed oil and OPC powder that's a
grape seed extract with antioxidant
properties that's very good for
connective tissue collagen and elastin
the paste is warmed up and applied to
help open the pores so that the active
ingredients can be absorbed
european-wide demand for health holidays
has risen by 40 percent in the last five
years many regions offer their own
specialties such as hay baths to
strengthen the immune system or Yoga to
bring body and mind into harmony
steam baths are a perennial favorite
[Music]
industry watchers expect the high growth
rates and wholesome getaways to continue
I mean one reason is that our everyday
lives have become quite stressful and
crammed full of activity I don't just
been worth their appointments courses
and other things so all the time people
are at home they're building up a need
to be looked after and many people have
enough disposable income to pay for
someone else to do it but the pampering
comes at a cost
these holidays are the higher priced
categories
an all-inclusive spa weekend in the
5-star hotels literally Lua will relieve
you of at least three hundred eighty
euros per person
for those who have splashed out don't
seem to regret it
Walter here is at 32° it's a great
temperature you can really relax holiday
is such a different experience after a
week of looking after your body and your
face you can return to your normal
professional life feeling much stronger
and resilient a chance to relax and find
yourself
that's something more and more Europeans
aim for
[Music]